[inaudible].
Good evening.
Good evening ladies and gentleman.
This evening is all about cycling,
so you might be wondering what a mere
her telia is doing here,
sharing this event.
But I am a very keen cyclist.
Um,
I got into cycling through triathlon,
which I took happy living 11 years ago
and,
uh,
cycling is a discipline I really like
mirrors and I think I'll give the other
two are,
uh,
very soon.
Um,
to be a keen cyclist,
you've got to be a bit of a masochist.
All cyclists keen sight is like riding
up hills as fast as they,
uh,
as like as,
as they can and uh,
and uh,
no exception.
But the thing that,
uh,
that I feel when I cycle,
I feel at one with the elements and I
feel a real feeling of par.
Uh,
and that's what really gets to me.
anyway,
the,
uh,
we've got six great speakers here this
evening.
They're going to have 12 minutes each to
speak.
After 10 minutes,
I'm going to give them a warning,
a warning bell,
uh,
at the end of the,
the f six presentations.
There'll be time for questions about 20
minutes.
Uh,
so I hope you'll have a lot of questions
to ask.
So without any more ado,
we'll go onto to the first speaker who
is a prolific author,
a,
she's called Bella bathurst.
And,
uh,
her latest book is a,
is a public,
uh,
is,
is a book called the,
the bicycle book.
Very appropriately Bella
[inaudible].